genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by fume have you ever
tried to break a bad habit and you felt
like you're climbing Everest in
flip-flops well guess what fume is here
to save the day fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavor air device that
does just that fume takes your habit and
simply makes it better healthier and a
whole lot more enjoyable it's awesome
The Taste is great and on top of that it
has movable these magnet parts that's
great for people who fidget and I use it
in traffic all the time so start the
year off right with the good habit by
going to Tri fume / genius and getting
the journey pack today fume is giving
listeners of the show 10% off when they
use michco genius to help make starting
the good habit that much easier start
the goodh Habit at tri.com gen save 10%
off the journey pack today
which Vince also did rolls into the me
equals exctly yes yes
yes oh
baby yeah oh yeah in 5 4 3 2 1 Welcome
everybody to the Vince McMahon
show Monday Night Raw Monday Night Raw
extra explicit a little too raw yeah
dude to SmackDown and Raw two in one
that's probably where I got the names
from hey before before we talk about
Vince McMahon I do want to preface this
with I'm going to call it ww
because I'm I'm getting tired of having
to sarch the WWE so if you guys don't
know the history behind that apparently
there's something called something
something Wildlife the World Wildlife
Foundation which is [__] nobody
[__] cares all right it's got a panda
as their logo and [__] them all right
they ruined my childhood they so
basically they sued the
WWF the WWE now yeah World Wrestling
Federation what it was yeah yeah which
was kind of interesting I just thought
that because there's two separate
entities that it would be fine I loved
the WWF that was our [__] it wasn't like
you know I think people now kind of
equate it to hillbilly like white people
[__] right no the WWF was for every
everyone everyone it we I slammed so
many people through tables at church
because just because we had we had the
tables so at church if you guys haven't
been to a cran church but like every
Sundays everybody would set up the
tables together right and so we had
those WWF tables and so we would set
them up and then if there was one that
was a little busted or rickety we would
[__] power bomb [__] do it blow
blow I loved it my favorite memory when
I was a kid my cousin skinny scrawny as
[__] I was fat as
[__] at the time he came on uh when we
were a little bit older it was Kurt
Angle former Olympic gold medalist right
right well he had the angle CT angle
slam which I thought was the [__]
coolest right you basically firearm
carry them over and you twist [__]
slam so I did this to him twice right so
the first time I did it it was great it
was fine and then you know we're broke
as [__] so we didn't actually have bed
frames we just had the metal ones that
kind came with the box spring and the
mattress problem with those things those
things are cheap as [__] so I Kurt Angle
slam this full and it bent my [__]
bed in half right
my dad got so [__] mad he beat the
living [__] out of me then he taged te
my
mom she [__] people's elbow I mean I
think I think everybody definitely went
through that phase of you know
practicing the finishing moves on on you
know your friend or like your little
brother your your cousin I definitely
did it the pedigree oh the pedigree that
pedigree was my favorite finisher cuz
that [__] was just epic you know yeah
boom and then um you would try to like
you know do it in a way where they don't
get hurt but obviously you're not a
professional fuing way they would always
say don't do this at home go [__] we're
doing this at home no like the um me and
like some of the homies that were super
into it when we were young we would we
would like kind of play it out at school
too like for example you know we would
like uh just jump a guy in the hallway
not like not for reals but you know
those scenes like they're walking in the
and they like come out of lock room yeah
ex it was kind of like that and then so
we kind of like fake H hit each other
but like go through the actual emotions
of like you know it's actually happening
and then people will be like oh [__]
like these guys are jumping them you do
the choke slams in the swimming pool oh
yeah people in the pool that way that's
right Rock Bottom in the swimming pool I
[__] that actually hurt though that
that bed that bent in half my dad was so
mad he made me sleep in it for like 2
months oh wow so I was I was sleep in
like a v two months
we practiced these moves on our little
sister and it broke my pet FR sister oh
my God my parents didn't get me a new
pet I slept like that I just had to
sleep like a [__] V for the longest
[__] time dude it [__] it started
[__] up my back and then they got me
like another metal frame which was just
free from somebody else you we're poor
we couldn't afford anything else and the
second time second time the last time I
started doing this stuff is same cousin
we were practicing uh Power bombing
obviously practicing he couldn't lift me
up cuz I was fat dude Power Bomb that
picks a lot of strength though oh yeah
he was skinny though like I said he was
skinny oh you did it to
him he's like hey let's try out power
BPS you go first oh you can't do it all
right my turn what I meant practice was
that he was the one just getting slapped
over oh man so I lifted him up yeah and
then I power bombed him onto our couch
right and it was [__] fun it was fun
for him too fun for me I was like let's
do it again but this time I [__]
lifted him too fast and it made me take
a step three steps back oh [__] and I
power P him into the Flor oh my God and
all I heard was
boom Oh man as the last time yeah I did
[__] WWE moves in the house cuz I
thought I [__] killed him dude yeah
dude Power Bomb onto the [__] floor
that [__] was the best though dude I
love that [__] well I mean but but let's
talk a little bit about that WWF error
because people might kind of not be
aware of it I mean especially if if
they're like you know in their teens
right now they might not know about
Ultimate Warrior they might not know
about Ted debiasi the Million dooll Man
they might not know about you know Shawn
Michaels Heartbreak Kid Brett Owen the
you know Hitman wait oh no Bret uh Brett
the Hitman Hart yeah um Owen Owen har
brother so that whole like that the
other thing too was like in before the
80s like wrestling was a territorial
thing right in every part of the of the
US
us the the rule was rule was just like
unoken they don't mess with each other's
businesses and that was under uh Vince
McMahon senior's Senor yeah but once he
passes on and the Vince McMan we all
know now he doesn't call himself junior
he went full on shark mode and took the
whole game over monopolized it right and
so through business practice is like
everybody out there even Dana White
would say Vince McMahon is like as a
businessman ker the killer yeah so that
and and then you'll see like Through The
Years other stories like people have of
him like he has this control thing where
he has to control everything so when
he's talked to him and then Vince
McMahon
sneezed he like got so upset at himself
he was like that shouldn't have happened
I should have been more control I not
have to the miror he was like you
f like seriously like he can't even like
like like sneeze without willingly
wanting to do it what the [__] that's a
weird mental thing that he has then well
you know we're going to obviously get
into like the meats of Vince McMahon too
but also like just kind of shedding
light a little bit on his childhood he
alluded to the fact that he was sexually
abused when he was younger um now did
that turn him to turn him out make him
turn out to be a [__] up individual I
don't know it doesn't excuse his current
behavior but it you know there there is
a little bit of kind of a [__] up [__]
that happened during his childhood I
think his physical and sexual abuse is
what he alluded to I mean that's
interesting that he has a issue with
control because there's so many stories
about like ww the WWF was so chaotic
like nothing ever went according to plan
no but that that was the thing that was
the illusion like he was he he scripted
it all the time no but I'm saying like
you hear all the stories everything went
wrong all the time always had to think
on the fly like the WWF was pure chaos
keep hearing stories from John Cena The
Rock even like Dave Batista he goes oh
you know this right here yeah [__]
tore my quad oh yeah this happened and
then Vince mcmah had to come through
like there was a famous story that uh
where Vince mcah
T that [__] was my running in to be part
of the show and then like when he got in
the [__] one quad tore both no no he
tore one quad initially he tried to get
up and he turned it wasn't at the same
time so he's sitting there and he's
trying to do his lines and then the
other cast's like what the [__] well
apparently he ran in that wasn't
scripted either he ran in because
something happened between them that
[__] up so he had to go in to do like
basically an intermission to kind of
tell them what to do next yeah yeah so
they could restart the script so that
was him trying to save the [__] day
and I didn't know your legs could
explode legs exploded dude I wonder how
he felt when Booker T watch we coming
for
you this [__] hid behind he was
like I lost my job that was so funny
Hulk Hogan that was my favorite favorite
moment of all time I've never seen
somebody so afraid that they were going
to lose their job like that dude I think
that was when he was in WCW yeah yeah
yeah so that was another thing when the
90s came WCW became a big thing and it
was their main competition right and by
that time it was something called The
Attitude Era where we went TV MA for
mature why because everyone who grew up
watching wrestling were older now and
wrestling for us yeah it was like kid
content yeah right so there was the the
story with uh Jake the Snake Roberts
when he brought the snake out and and
like um he got people bit and stuff that
was like oh my gosh that sounds so real
but the kids right but as we got older
it was like that whole notion of all
wrestling wring fake wrestling's fake
came on and they were like okay so how
do we retain our audience that take it
to the next level it to the next level
what was the moment for you guys when
you realized how fake wrestling was
because I remember as a kid arguing with
people that it was real that everything
was [__] real I actually know the
moment I realized it was fake I don't
know if I had a singular moment where I
thought it was fake yeah it could have
been like some fake punches but there
was also a moment I think I remember
someone was like oh on the ground and
then he pulled something out and
did like this started so mine was that
too it was raki raki fell if you guys
don't know who raki is big old Hawaiian
dude big old cake cellulite all over the
place his finishing move was basically
having somebody [__] eat their eat
his ass it was [__] disgusting and if
you listen to the accounts of other WWF
wrestlers like Kurt Angle he goes I
[__] hated it he goes I hate it when
I have to go against him because he knew
what would happen and then you know for
him before the F he's just like sorry
brother but he basic I'm not sure if he
was Hawaiian or he was Simone either or
some Polynesian right yeah
so he falls over and he goes under the
ring right and then I see the razor
comes out and then he's bleeding and I'm
like I remember as a kid I was like this
[__] is fake as [__] I was so upset
because I remember arguing with like
older people that it was real and then
you I felt so stupid I felt betrayed and
I think after that that's when I stopped
watching it it started like ciling in
'93 the UFC comes out yep and that was
their whole thing like this [__] is real
and then you're like uh well I mean but
look you know the even though I knew it
was fake early on I watched it for
entertainment like I knew it was
scripted I knew like [__] was going to
get crazy I mean like come on Stone Cold
[__] like t-boning Vince's car and
[__] like dude he would be dead in an
instant the way it show
I was so young it was just it was so
entertaining there was a lot of fainted
ignorance on my part like even have you
seen that uh video of that old dude like
he's he's there's a Q&A with some other
wrestler yeah and he's just like I just
want to say that you have changed my
life and and then he's like and when
people say it's not real it's real to me
damn it like you know it's like you want
to faint inance cuz this is like
something you enjoy right and so for me
too like after a while like by the time
I was in middle school high school it's
like I had to hide the fact that I
watched it no I I I didn't care I mean I
watched it pretty hardcore till like I
would say mid High School right I mean
fun some of my funnest memories is
watching with my Harmony she [__]
loved watching WWE WC it didn't matter
it
was sometimes the Luchador stuff from
Mexico would be on in LA TV and that was
way more hard that was different dude
their [__] was acrobatic as [__] if you
lost they would sh it's like basically
20 Ray Mysterio the whole time dude
shout outs to my grandma her favorite
show
Cops you know what she would call the
show she would call Bad Boys yeah she
okay yeah cuz the song Bad Boy to Bad
Boy and she used to love watching people
get arrested that she like turned her on
or
something
I love a Justice
support but anyway let's talk about uh
business man is sex
trafficking this is probably okay now
we've already known the past three years
we've heard so much stuff come out you
know dark Hollywood [__] right I mean we
could even start with the Epstein whole
Epstein Island thing right well Harvey
wiin let's start you know from there
let's start with like the Harvey weining
which is so interesting which you know I
I kind of don't
understand like the human psyche when it
comes to this type of stuff right not so
much in the sense of what they were
doing about the audience like the
audience knows about this stuff that
happens in Hollywood and then they just
don't care about it anymore yeah they
kind of just go oh that happened that's
crazy and they move on and they still do
whatever the [__] that they're doing
it's a symptom of the times too just
because like you know with technology
with your phones you're just constantly
bombarded with new information new thing
that's going to grab your attention or
new thing you should be outraged about
excited about sad about and then it's
like like you said oh man that happened
okay scroll and then you're on to the
next [__] how the [__] so was stepen
Hawkins he was legit on that list yep I
thought that was a ho on that island and
he was there having you know sex parties
with little
people it's yeah and they would set up
like a chalkboard for him oh and naked
little he would have naked little people
do like equations get the [__] how is
this wait how does how do people know
this [__] do that
equation yes solve for y that is so
specific that's like a very specific
Kink I think it was like because of a
email Epstein put out saying hey this is
what he wants I mean but the thing is
it's like oh my God it it's like people
are weird to begin with and when you're
given the option to just be completely
Unchained and and let your wildest
[__] fantasies and dreams just play
out in front of you I mean this the kind
of [__] you're going to hear right what
the [__] so he had little people do math
equations naked yeah and he would just
what watch
them said I think in the email
somethingone was like yeah it still
works so like what the [__] is going on
I don't know if you could get a boner
but he's like he could feel it or
something genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by fume have
you ever tried to break a bad habit and
felt like you're climbing Everest and
flip-flops yeah well we've all been
there too but here's a breath of fresh
air fume it's not about giving up it's
about switching up it fume takes your
habit and simply makes it better
healthier and a whole lot more enjoyable
what is fume you ask fume is a
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that and instead
of vapor fume uses flavored Air instead
of electronics fume it's completely
natural and instead of harmful chemicals
fume uses delicious flavors you get it
instead of bad fume is good it's a habit
you're free to enjoy and makes replacing
your bad habit easy I use mine when I'm
stuck in traffic and I get bored it has
movable parts and magnets for people who
fidget a lot which I really enjoy a lot
and that's why I use it so start the
year off right with a good habit by
going to
trium.vira
save 10% off the journey pack today yeah
I don't know man that that is the
craziest [__] I've ever ever heard in my
life hey look man people are into some
weird [__] that gets them off some
people are into [__] bleeding some
people are into [__]
which vce also did rolls into the room
me
equals yes yes
yes oh
[Laughter]
baby oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah well
without King shaming we want to say look
you got a find a partner who will
consent yeah yeah if you don't find
somebody else instead they play this
[__] power trip and to them it's like
the satisfaction comes from getting it
from someone who doesn't want yeah I
mean I I think you know we can kind of
correlate it to what we had talked about
with um the the brothel with with the
whole K-pop Scandal and the actors you
know it's like an exclusive Club where
the Rich and Famous or you don't even
have to be famous you could just be rich
right has access to whatever they want
without worrying well it's supposed to
be anyway it's supposed to be a safe
haven where they don't have to worry
about public criticism or Paparazzi and
they could basically do whatever the
[__] they want which is why they uh go
to places like that or or you know
befriend people like Jeffrey Epstein
because they give them access to that
they're like yeah I got my I got my
rocks that I need to get off and this
guy is letting me do that or this
wonderment if anybody that was like in
those email threads or chains they just
had normal request like what if they
went to the island and they just read
this email and it was just like I just
want like I want I want three women
there that's going to listen to my
feelings they're just like that's I
don't I don't think that's what that
Island was for man dude I just wanted
some pineapple slices what going person
like can I just have beef water and like
beef jerky and water they're like what
the [__] are you doing on this island
look I'm sure there were times when the
island wasn't only used for you know
sexual deviant Behavior would have a lot
of just rich people secluded yeah like
the Suare and [__] my question is too
about that right is that what about like
is everybody getting flamed for what
about staff right cuz that place was
staffed the [__] out yeah you know Maids
cleaning people Cooks uh [__]
janitorial services are they all getting
flamed too I mean they they've been
questioned you know they've been
questioned about it and some of them did
do do speak out if you look at like
documentaries and stuff but you know
let's be honest man people don't care
about the staff they care about the big
names right yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz if
they're just there doing that are they
getting flamed too it's like what they
were just there working well I think I
think some of the staff alludes to the
fact that like they thought something
was kind of off but they didn't know
yeah it was just like that's none of my
business type [__] don't tell yeah I'm
getting paid to do a job and I'm pretty
sure they told him hey you're not
allowed to say [__] if you do your fault
I mean apparently Jeffrey Epstein wasn't
like Vince going around hey look at
this look look at it does that turn you
on you like that yeah like Vince would
go into a room of full of the the TV
people crew right just slobs and like
show him pictures and like hey he she'll
[__] all of you at once but let's let's
start from the vinc mag thing from the
okay okay let me so let me read um the
some parts from the lawsuit what is
alleging that uh Vince had done so a
former WWE staffer has accused the
company's founder Vince McMahon of
sexual assault trafficking and physical
abuse in a lawsuit filed Thursday I mean
this was before but yeah the new
disturbing allegations from Janelle
Grant who worked at WWE's headquarters
come more than a year after the
conclusion of a WWE appointed special
committee investigation into McMahon's
alleged miscon misconduct while serving
as chairman and CEO of the company um
and then it goes in the lawsuit filed in
Connecticut District Court Grant alleged
that McMahon promised a job and later
promotions at WWE in exchange for sex
Grant's lawsuit also includes
allegations that McMahon trafficked her
to other men inside and outside of the
company including John laurenitis a
former wrestler who worked with the
company's Talent Relations Department um
and then there's a there's a there's a a
quote in here that says early in the
counter big manah immediately directed
Miss Grant to lay down on her back in a
supplicating position uh while
straddling over her McMahon defecated on
Miss Grant's head so this is this is one
of God get the [__] out of here dude
okay so and then and then it goes on to
say while uh Strat and defecated on her
head McMahon left to shower off but he
instructed Miss Grant to remain in place
with extra excrement in her hair and to
continue performing for his
friend so he wouldn't even let her do
wipe it up even if somebody out there is
like I need proof for this right that is
so specific it's kind of hard not to
believe at that point dude it's it's so
like why would you how could you make
that up yeah yeah and and and the fact
that there's another person that she's
supposed to quote unquote
service with [__] on her and and the
fact that this dude has no problem with
it do people even know how bad human
[__]
smells it is it's [__] horri well and
and this other dude ended up becoming or
ended up being identified as Vince's
physical therapist so it wasn't just
some Rando it's wow B man is such a
caring guy I take care of my people I
mean so he so the dude had to watch
Vince take a [__] on her head and then
she sucked him off or some [__] with
[__] in while while Vince went to go
clean off he said no you stay there and
he had sex with her with [__] or
whatever hair yeah how do you have a
boner dude that's what like that's what
I'm say people get off on the weirdest
[__] I mean that's a whole [__]
category like scat like people get off
on that [__] bro I remember the first
time I learned about it was in high
school somebody was like Hey you ever
check out scat babes.com and I was like
what's
that it's just a bunch of
people and then so I went to scat bab I
bro I was [__] horrified I was like
how the [__] is this a thing I went my
whole life without Watching Two Girls
One Cup hey ditto high five I can't do
it every everybody has tried to get me
to watch it send me stupid [__] links
I can't watch that yeah by the time I
found out about it I already knew what
it was and I'm like I don't need to
revisit that someone already told me
what I was so I'm like why you why would
I yeah why would I want to watch that
I've already seen scat babes.com
I I'm WF before WWE dude I've already
seen it all oh my God but yeah so so
like she she was promised a job in
exchange for sex well even before that
like uh she just lived in his building
and her parents had passed away and I
guess she was struggling
financially uh Vince I guess kind of
like took her under his wing and and
said under his ass well eventually yeah
like he groomed her yeah pretty much
pretty muched was at the time I don't
know I think she was in her 20s probably
or I mean grooming is grooming it
doesn't have to necessarily be an
underage child but his intentions were
clear
so initially it was like a sexual
relationship between them two and then
it became uh like group sex and then it
became trafficking and then it became
getting [__] on the head like like every
step of the way she was hesitant didn't
want to do it yeah yeah it just
progressed more and more and it it it
you know it just shows how much of a
depraved individual Vince McMahon really
is but I think it also says a lot when
and a lot of the Public's reaction was
we're not surprised like it's not that
surprising yeah it's foul but given his
past yeah how long has this been going
on for I mean so he's had other um hush
money cases that he he paid off women
for it to disappear I think there were
like four other cases for God damn yeah
in in in the past I don't know 15 20
years and then this one too I mean he
did try to pay pay her off and have her
sign an NDA which is absolutely
ridiculous like it doesn't work with the
crime yeah exactly well the part of it
was like the reason why this came out
was cuz he ended up not paying her well
so he paid a million of the 3 million I
think that he was supposed to and then
he stopped and then she was like okay
well [__] that like now I'm going to
take it public is he stupid he has a
gajillion dollar it's 3 mil is nothing
to you dude yeah like it doesn't make
any [__] sense I power control yeah
that's that's what I'm I'm not going to
let her [__] do this to me all four
other women already did it's cuz his
wife found out and to end things like
that it was like okay here's the deal 3
million but NDA right and then out of
spite he just didn't pay her yeah just
his while his ego is that bad it's like
dude this is going to destroy your whole
life your rep reputation your career
your company Legacy and simply just
because I'm not going to let somebody do
this to me even though you you did
something wrong which is the weirdest
he's the architect of the whole thing
you know what's his moral stance on this
is like extortion is wrong you [__]
sex woman the [__] are you talking about
you trash bag yeah so I mean I I'm think
this been going on since the beginning
like from the 80s long time yeah for
sure yeah well I mean there was you know
he's done very questionable and Shady
things um in the past that have
obviously come to light even more or
people found out about even more now
because of of these recent allegations
but you know take uh Superfly Jimmy
schnuer for example right in the 80s
like we we we know him right he he was a
wrestler that we enjoyed watching but it
turns out I think back in the 80s um his
girlfriend died suddenly and he called
the police saying that oh she hit her
head and then went to uh back to their
her hotel room and then she fell asleep
and then she apparently passed away in
her sleep right that was his story yeah
now he got booked Under Suspicion right
Vince apparently came with the suitcase
talked with the cops for about an hour
and then all of a sudden hey you're free
to go wow wow Cas skull's
cold they say oh yeah um it was an
accident it it's uh it was it was just a
freak accident type of situation
Corner's report says no it's not
consistent with what he's saying that
it's not just the simple head bump this
is actually showing signs of assault um
and it should be investigated as a
homicide but he got away with it for
like 30 30 years yeah and then he went
to jail yeah is there like there's no
statute of limitations for murder yeah I
don't think I think it's just as far as
it goes you're [__] right that's the
same thing that happened with uh Tupac's
killer supposedly this guy's over here
just going I killed him it was me you
know for some [__] odd reason that
I'll never understand you know Vince in
in his uh move to protect his money
maker paid off the cops seemingly and
was able to yeah get him scotf free let
him make him go these cops get in
trouble too well they probably retired
by then oh they might even be dead at
this point you know what I mean yeah
everyone's elderly now right but yeah I
mean the the shady [__] goes back to
like the steroid abuse that was coming
out and they were trying to hide that
[__] um the drug abuse obviously Chris
Ben W all that [__] it was just like
they were fueling his mental illness
Yeah by making him go out there every
week when he should have been I mean
Chris story was pretty tragic too he
killed his family didn't he killed his
family and then he killed himself they
were kind of acquainting that to him
having um
CT with the painkiller addiction and all
yeah but you know
WWE kind of like swept that under the
rug and just kind of more so glorified
him to to make it like hey let's
remember that who murderer until it came
out that he murdered his wife and kids
oh right right right right right I mean
like the other thing was they swept Owen
Hart's death under the rug and it was
like they were liable for that and then
they they try the same thing like
glorify like his life and all that but
his wife behind the scenes were like you
killed him yeah you know so she she won
a lawsuit too so it's like there's a
paper trail of just [__] behavior and
[__] business practices that go a long
way uh there was another guy who was an
announcer right um long story short it
was a big competition to be the next WWE
announcer so all over America and then
this guy won right out of all these
candidates they and so he got a job at
WWE and in two weeks he was fired right
and he came out saying that Pat
Patterson came on to him and he was a
vice president at the time he came on to
him yeah wow so Pat Patterson was openly
gay oh was he okay I didn't know that he
was the first gay wrestler okay yeah um
but he came on to this dude and then he
was just like not having it two weeks
later he's fired wow and then Vince
mcmah started defaming him and said he
was a [__] announcer and all that and
he's like really I want a competition
amongst all the candidates and I get
fired at after yeah I mean but you know
there were plenty of public feuds
between like the talent and Vince and
you know they would always try to make
it seem like oh yeah they're just
disgruntled ex employees Montreal screw
job yeah that right with Brett yeah
that's I wonder twoo it's like I wonder
how this is going to work and reflect
upon like the rock right cuz he's worked
so close and hand in hand and he's on
the board of WWE right now too well oh
yeah that it just happened this week I
think it was hand inand with Vince
having to get out and they called The
Rock yo get on board they needed to save
the WWE image yeah so so actually that's
a good point of bringing somebody like
the rock up is that like such a clean
image how much was known within MH
within the company CU there's no way you
could be a part of that company and not
know a little if Vince is going around
to just his you know regular employees
and and being like you know
like every time we imitate him well
that's what he is a [__] creepy yeah
you don't want to read back those texts
in his voice no no but but but no the
the thing is even uh an unnamed uh
wrestler was promised uh sex with I
think Janelle Grant in exchange to
signing yeah that was Brock Les was it
Brock Les was it confirmed that it's
Brock Lesnar it was Brock Lesnar okay
cuz I I was seeing that it was allegedly
Brock Lesnar but I don't know if it got
confirmed yeah so they were he was uh
UFC and he was a free agent and then
anybody like he could have done anything
literally but then they wanted him bad
enough that they you know set up this
dinner with him and this girl and then
Brock Lesnar got pissed
drunk and so they had to carry him back
to his hotel room so it couldn't happen
oh I see and so that's when Vince
McMahon came in and be like well since
Brock's not like he cosplayed as Brock
Lesnar oh Jesus and just ragged all her
like beat the [__] out of her choked her
out like it even says he fisted
her this girl that's in the
lawsuit so he was going to use her to
have sex with Brock Lesnar that [__]
Bear yeah so it was in exchange for
signing him like it was a perk or bonus
to the contract basically Brock Lesnar's
in trouble too then huh well well
nothing happened cuz he got yeah he got
he apparently yeah he got drunk but even
if he didn't that was the intended thing
that he was going to do he was
essentially going to sexually assault
this woman well there was there was a
quote that apparently was said of like
oh that's all you Vince like if I run
through that you know you're not going
to be yeah it's not going to feel good
for you anymore type of [__] like he
said something like that so I think
maybe he him try to say I don't want to
do this yeah like I'm cool you know
thanks but I'm good cuz he doesn't want
to piss off the boss so he's just like
nah I can't I can't do that still I mean
dude this is like the weird part too
like morality speaking right
like if you know about stuff like this
right and you still end up working for
the company what does that say about you
right and this goes hand in hand with a
lot of Hollywood people too just in
general outside of the WWE yeah right
there's so many people who like to point
their fingers at other stuff that's
happening and I for example I will
always use that uh David Cho thing going
on right they knew about all that stuff
they still hired him that goes on the
whole people the creators of of beef it
goes with Steven Yun it goes for all
these guys right and look these are
people that I Stephen you as an actor I
[__] love this guy right but you knew
so do these people get to walk away like
oh Stephen you this great guy it's like
well you knew about these quote unquote
allegations which at the time maybe you
did or didn't know that it was true or a
fake story and you still decided to work
with him so do you get to walk away
scratch free are you this person that
gets to walk around as if you're this
morally sound human being I don't know
right yeah I mean it's tough because I
think in that situation um like when
you're in a monopoly you control
everything and that's your only shot to
you know pursue your dreams and but you
have to go through this [__] hell to
get it yeah I mean that's the problem
like same with like Amazon we're all
like upset about how they treat Amazon
workers but where else are we going to
get our [__] yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like like do we all just have like
a little like blood on our hands like
for everything that we do even when we
use our phones as [__] the whatever
the minerals that's for the cell phones
like do we all just have to deal with
this [__] yeah because if you look
at it we're probably guilty of it on
some level too of like oh you know some
soand so has an allegation or like a you
know some something that somebody said
about them but we still enjoy their
entertainment whatever they they're
entertaining us with right KN Kelly at
the wedding type yeah yeah R Kelly um I
mean I don't want to say Michael Jackson
because it was nothing was proven yeah
right but yes things like that I mean we
even talked about this before about
Kanye right there's so many people who
still like [__] are are are Glazer
for yay like they they will defend them
no matter what but you and I had talked
about it and I told you that I can't
listen to yay anymore and to the point
where I removed them from all my
playlists like I thoroughly thoroughly
enjoyed the music that he had put out
and you know was a big part of like my
youth
but it's like it gets to a certain point
where it's like hey man enough is enough
bro like and and and so I think it it
all depends on the individual I mean
there was even a case in the past like
when we were working on music where an
opportunity to get placements with
certain artists was on the table but
like knowing what that artist had done
I'm not going to name the name but made
me like N I don't even want to pursue
that opportunity like [__] that guy [__]
that guy like I don't know if we're
talking about the same person but then
yeah like I know of a guy with
allegations and what ever I did was to
stay away from that Circle yeah yeah and
then I have friends that are like in
that Circle I'm like and I don't know
that's another thing where I'm
conflicted like am I supposed to tell
them cuz they're my friend like yo these
are the rumors and start like saying
these things that aren't proven you know
I mean it's hard for me right like it
most people are not confrontational
right so I would say 99% of the world
from what I'm finding out they're not
confrontational because it's
uncomfortable it's understandable right
to it's easier to just ignore it than
having to face something upfront right
and I'm saying I'm saying that as well
because like I didn't realize this inste
like talking to started talking to most
people right because people look at me
as a very confrontational human being
but usually what I do is I just address
things that are in front of me because
it bothers me later so sometimes too
whether it's emails or interactions like
I know somebody who recently had like
certain allegations about them and it
wasn't me coming at them I just talked
to them was like so we're friends so
what happened here and they explained MH
and then as a friend I have a choice to
believe it or not right and if it sounds
sound then as a friend I'll be like okay
that sounds like it makes sense to me
that sucks so I'll just leave it at that
but I have to at least do that for for
my conscience anyways you know what I
mean cuz it's going to bother me yeah
all the [__] time it's I look at this
person and that's what I see yeah so
it's it's hard right and I know like I'm
not saying
that I've done it all the time but
that's why I'm just kind of bringing up
this question it's like do how much do
people know and how much do people get
away with right like are you are you
guilt-free because you were just an Arms
Reach away from him even though you knew
it was happening but then again I
empathize too because how hard is it for
that person to come up and just start
saying things about them when they maybe
they don't even actually know yeah right
it's like like the Cosby thing maybe
they didn't actually know but they have
an inkling they heard a story so do you
get to do you have the right to come up
and just be like you did this when you
actually don't know what if you're wrong
yeah so it's like cuz you would hate for
that to happen to you so there's like
all these thoughts that kind of go in
your right and and I think you kind of
hit it on the head right there is that
like if maybe they're aware of it but
not sure and so instead of just blasting
away of something they're not sure about
instead yeah they'll keep their mouth
shut just do whatever it is they're
supposed to do and keep it pushing and
then they get the your compliant right
right but then when it comes out and
that is true then it's like oh [__] I
might be you know what's interesting too
we talked about on an episode about the
whole K-pop fandom thing and I mentioned
about this K-pop person that I met that
was kind of what he's he him in that
group he's actually in jail oh is for
for like sex trafficking or something
okay so it all kind of [__] made
sense I was like oh [__] cuz I looked it
up I was like what's this guy up to I'm
like oh he's in jail yeah so I was like
oh well there it is it all [__] works
out gets but look man I think like I was
saying earlier we're all guilty of it on
some level it's just to like what extent
you know and it's like where do you draw
that Line in the Sand and with with the
situation guy like Vince MC man who
[__] named his sex toys after the
wrestlers oh yeah according to their
race yeah yeah what the this one's like
Mark Henry or something yeah this dude
has like [__] obsession with
Blackhawks 2 you know it's just like
what is wrong with he can't stop talking
about BBC that's why [__] uh Booker T
got to keep his job wonder what he had
to do no but yeah I mean you know a
situation like that this this [__]
horor horrible depraved individual who
who doing these things pretty openly it
seems like how guilty are the people
around them do you say they're enablers
that's the thing there's a there must be
a huge list of names because they they
always say to the thing is like oh you
are complicit you are complicit and the
reason why like I said I don't like that
because a lot of people who say those
type of things you are that too like if
I if you were put into these situations
where you didn't know exactly you just
had an inkling and then you're going to
be that person that stands up and then
starts accusing people of stuff that
you're not sure about yeah I don't think
that's most people yeah yeah no I I
agree that's not even me either I would
have to definitively know before I go
out and I say something and and I think
it's much easier to criticize when
you're just watching something hearing
something reading something than to
actually be in that position like let's
say a wrestler had worked 20 years of
his life day in day out just to [__]
get to the WWE finally gets that
contract here's some [__] about Vince
Through the Grapevine maybe that
wrestler didn't know and then he's like
well I [__] sacrificed like the
better part of my life for this am I
going to [__] go on this you know uh
finally pay my bills I don't have going
to go on you know [__] Instagram
stories or start tweeting about what I
heard about Vince or am I just going to
[__] put my head down do my job or
like now back in the day there wasn't
social media like this right they didn't
have the court of the general internet
of peers to go ahead and rain down
because at that point money was power
right so there was nobody else there was
only here he said she said about certain
things so let's say for example
something happened it's like well it's
my word against the most powerful person
in this industry who the [__] is going
to believe me and then I'll get fired
then I'll lose my job people will then
he'll make stories about me just like
what happened to that announcer so
there's also fearmongering that's
happening too so you just don't know
yeah the intimidation factor is real for
sure especially with a guy like Vince
right who's so aggressive and has the
power status and money it's hard to you
know like you said at a time when social
media was in um a part of our daily
lives to go against a [__] Juggernaut
like that I mean that's why there's like
organizations like aew and I bet you
every single one of them hate Vince
McMahon and they're they want to go
there because it's none of that [__]
right yeah I'm I'm going to give you
guys a little snippet of some of these
texts and I'm going to change a lot of
the words just to show you how [__]
gruesome it is because we could talk
about it all right but if to read it out
loud I'm obviously there's some worse
texts this is this one's this is where
it begins yeah he writes to Janelle he
goes I love it that's you Janelle okay
we'll do the
voice you just can't get enough can you
in the future it's going to be so bad
that you'll de demand to be smashed I'm
replacing words twice twice a day and
not just with person in a three-way why
not let others see the beautiful
voluptuous body and watch you shake
uncont uncontrollably when you explode
they'll go out of their minds and this
is first of all dude this is the longest
text I've ever read in my life it's like
walls a wall of trash yeah he's writing
fu yeah he's writing a [__] novel
Talking in porn cliche yes what kind of
weirdo [__] are you just go to the
comment section and por up ex the fact
that this is a 70-year-old well at the
time a 70y old man texting this bro you
know and and and he's like randomly
capitalizing [__] like just words at
random just capitalizing like you and
you know this reminds me of what is it
called when they uh I heard it's a
phrase I saw somebody told me on JK news
where it's like
they'll write fandom about like
celebrities and like create like porn
scenario this is how he's writing yeah
fanfic fan Wheels knows what's up my boy
I don't write I don't write
it yeah fanfic yeah fanfic right so
they'll do th this is what it sounds
like he's a sick weird look at this [__]
dude then I'll find more friends and
we'll tie you up so you're helpless I'll
direct them to have their way way any
they any I'll direct them to have their
way any way they want exclamation mark
who can make you scream the loudest
quadruple exclamation mark maybe I'll
just line them up and have them squirt
in your mouth this guy I swear to God he
wanted a stage and a mic to say [__] for
real dude I think he's like performing
what he does on the WWF when he's on
stage this is some weird [__] yeah and
and one thing I mean obviously the whole
thing is heinous but one thing in
particular that just [__] irked me
was he kept spelling [__] with an ey oh
he's French dude I was like what like
hey yeah like the biggest crime of all
is spelling [__] with that e no and
then here's here's the text about the um
him sharing it with the workers uh I
just passed my phone around to a bunch
of guys on the tech crew they were
screaming oh my God she's [__]
beautiful look at that ass I'd like to
get that I paused to count out loud how
many guys there were 12 I then said okay
there's 12 of you and she would love to
f each and every one of you at one time
the guys cheered but she will only do it
if she takes three at a time what that
brought a huge reaction let her know
yeah get ready like what I mean what the
[__] and then and then he goes on to the
some you know explicit details of how
this thing would unfold it sounds like
yeah he got off on telling her and
saying this [__] power her yeah you know
control right so um he really does have
an obsession with black penis
it's like I'm reading more of these
texts how many times can he say black
dick why do you have to continually say
this so many times you need your panties
ripped off in three black dicks in all
three holes at the same time [__] is
wrong with this weigh up your
P yeah this guy this guy is just he's a
[__] Menace you know um he's like
okay if you guys ever have the time to
read this or if you have the wherewithal
too it's so descriptive he might as well
have counted the hair in her [__] at
this point it's so graphically
descriptive it's like it's it's almost
hilarious to me because he's just like
let me just give you the most amount of
evidence possible to [__] me over in the
future and let me write it in text with
very very specific descriptions let me
write a novel to you um what are you
dumb you know one of the most disturbing
um things that was brought to light with
this was that Janelle Grant was saying
that
there were times when she said no and
they said no means yes and they would
continue to and she said yes and it goes
gotcha like what the [__] no no she
would continually say no and they would
continually rape her at that point
pretty much you know um then these are
other WWE employees yeah hey let me tell
you something girl 3 million was not
enough well yeah this was going on
before during and after work on like
work hours this isn't just off sight
[__] that's the thing this is why WWE is
also liable as a right so the thing is
in that lawsuit there is no she's not
asking like for a specific number but
she's going to get way more than EEG
Caroll did off of trump if you guys
don't know the news Trump um in the in a
court of law it was he was found to be
liable for raping or sexually assaulting
her at a department store and then uh
she wrote about it in a memoir
and then he went on to call her all
these names and and stuff and so Trump
siop Fant attacked her with like death
threats and all that so she sues him for
defamation she wins uh tens of millions
of dollars then Trump goes on again
again to defame her so the second case
won her $83 million yeah now whether or
not she's going to get it is a different
story um I mean he said on the stand
that he has 400 cash 400 mil cash yeah
but good luck trying to you know
actually get that from him
right he's dumb too yeah he's he's it's
like okay so you lost the 10 mil let me
just lose another 80 he ego the ego they
will not it will not allow them to
accept that situation it just won't I
think on the stand they asked the the
asked him like why why' you continue you
know saying these things and it was just
like he wanted to hurt her that's why I
mean that's it yeah which is like was
that worth the 83 mil to like make your
crazy fans go after her like he was
hoping that in turn she would get hurt
make her stop talking right that's
[__] evil well I mean look I don't
think there's any mystery about the
character of this guy this is so weird
right and these types of people we're
seeing it's it's it's the whole thing
too when I you know when we have this
conversation with other people and I
always advise them to understand that
you know when somebody says bad things
about you online with the blah blah blah
blah it's it's always bigger in your
head than you actually think that it is
right obviously in this case is probably
not the greatest example right but even
for somebody like me I didn't even know
about this right but now I do yeah right
but some some people get so obsessed
when somebody dislikes them or some
somebody says something bad about them
that it becomes like an ego and Power
Trip they can't let it go so what is
something that's a a situation that's
this big maybe in their mind it's like
this they will never take the L it's
it's a [__] agel story of Hollywood
right I mean it it's we we see it time
and time again we've seen it time and
time again in our lives and it it's
always going to be the case but again
it's like well knowing this what do you
do with that information do you continue
to consume you know this entertainment
coming out from this organization not
knowing who was guilty who was not or do
you just say well I see what happened
but I still find this enjoyable so I'm
I'm going to continue to watch I'm going
to continue to you know support this
company and um that's it I move on with
my life I mean it's hard to say it's
hard to say to each their own with that
like for me I can't ever separate that
you know what I mean this is this is
pretty [__] bad I think like the the
thing that I was kind of disappointed in
the most was like when you go online and
you read comments from these guys
they're like well what's the full story
of this well she got money out of this
right it's like listen dude have you
read those texts do you think any amount
of money like $3 million which is
[__] absolutely nothing yeah she
can't buy a house with that exactly this
woman got [__] raped Yeah by multiple
men at the same time and here's the
here's the thing too is that like um
people I think were asking why she
decided to come forward with it and she
was saying that it's not just about me
it's to also speak out for the other
women who are scared to to say something
about Vince 100% this isn't the only
girl yeah 100% 100% so like that the
four hush money cases aside I'm sure
there's many other women yeah who are
involved in this or entangled in this
whole you know situation but just are
scared to speak out and you got to
understand too for her in this case too
and how I see it as it's like also her
reputation as a woman is wrecked like
she has been ran through I mean the
social implications of that from what
most how most people feel about women
right yeah and her photo got out too and
her photo her face everything like
there's so much things on the line and
so when I read like some of these like
douchebag guys are on there they're like
well you did it for the money oh really
she got her head [__] on for three I
don't give a [__] how much money you
know what I'm saying like this is
[__] crazy like that shouldn't even
be and look we know we've heard the
stories about women who have tried to do
this right but you got to look at things
by Case by case right you can't just go
ahead and use a wide brush and start
painting all these victims with the same
thing go Case by case yeah and let's
also point out too some people might be
hearing this and might even be defending
Vince as horrible as that might be like
Kate Brothers yeah saying oh she
willingly did all this she wanted this
yeah you got clothes yeah you got a job
you got gifts you got jewelry what are
you complaining about this is what you
asked for but no that that's not what
she asked for and there are clear look
I'm gonna I'm gonna read a text here I
mean this kind of pretty much sums it up
he goes uh exactly babies baby he's not
the only one blank called me this
afternoon begging to eat you and [__]
you with his nice hard dick and then she
goes give me another week baby and I'll
be ready I'm feeling more like myself
it's not great but it's getting better
tell him soon basically alluding to the
fact that she has not been wanting to
engage in this type of [__] and he goes
I already told him baby by the way
Johnny wants Tuesdays but not this
coming one and the occasional Saturday
but maybe I could shift to the Thursday
like this guy is talking about it like
he's just [__] shifting around the
meeting you know what I mean or like
like a plan he ass for a lunch or and
it's like how can you defend this over
this person yeah like and I think you
know the people who might be defending
Vince in this case aren't aware of the
fact that like do you know guys know
what sex trafficking is right like when
you're under the thumb somebody like
that who's manipulative who has power
who has money
just saying no clearly doesn't work
right and sometimes you just feel
trapped it's like it's like uh you know
people who are in abusive relationships
it's not because necessarily they're
stupid and they don't know that they're
getting abused they're they just feel
powerless helpless and and kind of
chained to this individual who's abusing
them or multiple individuals in this
case who's who's abusing them and so
there's nothing to [__] defend here
it's horrible it's it's an outage and
this [__] should go to jail for
the rest of his life to be honest um but
that that's that's the thing the defense
part when they're saying he got her all
these gifts yeah because of what he did
to her doesn't make up for that doesn't
make it better yeah like she clocked in
for a job like a regular 9 to5 dude yeah
dude she got [__] trafficked to a
bunch of men and was used and
abused Hospital like he would put toys
that weren't supposed to go into her and
it got stuck and she had was
experiencing bleeding for days yeah like
that's [__] nuts what do you think
like a [__] mink coat makes it all
better this is the Legion of Doom coming
you know like but um yeah it it's it's a
pretty sad situation cuz she obviously
has things like PSD I mean no amount of
money is going to help fix this woman
that's the thing too like what what is
what is the cost for this what is the
price tag like there is no price tag for
this I'm surprised she I'm literally
actually kind of surprised she only
asked for 3 million I was like I would
[__] well I don't think she asked for it
that's what he offered her yeah he said
this is what I'm going to give you um
and also he kind of like guilt tripped
her he's like hey if you don't do this
like this stuff is going to get out
there it's going to hurt me it's going
to hurt Linda like employees yeah is
like do you want to really do that you
know and so again the manipulation he's
using he's he's using his power his
money his influence and and he's like
emotionally manipulating manipulating
her and making her think oh man yeah I
don't want to be a bad person I don't
want to hurt somebody else even though
she's getting hurt for for years of her
life by this guy um emotionally and
physically yeah yeah and so [__] that
[__] Vince that's what it comes down to
[__] that guy dude well guys that wraps
up this episode of The Genius brain
podcast uh let me know what you guys
think in the bottom have you guys read
about this have you heard about this
this is pretty [__] insane I just
found out about Stephen Hawkins uh you
asking for little people to do math
equations uh yeah I didn't know the
detail of that either I knew he was on
the list but that's [__] wild yeah
I'm not sure if the the the chalkboard
was the joke part but then like the
little people thing was the real yeah
that was that was for real that's wild
man well genius brain every Sunday's at
12:00 p.m. you guys could catch us every
Sundays at 12: p.m. give us a like WR in
the comments below share with your
friends get those views up you guys can
cop secret society s CTS o c
et.com for your highquality fashion
basic needs you could catch Ed at EDP
Park VP and also Ed at Ed 2 Ed has his
own podcast called Bible studyed Bible
study at Momo uh Momo or Momo Momo Momo
uh jeans spr every Sunday at 12: p.m.
we'll see you all next time peace peace
peace